so
deadly riots over the government's plan
to avoid defaulting on its loans is that
the unemployment keeps rising and it has
to keep rising just because so much
[Music]
now my grandmother was a wonderful
person
she taught me how to play the game
monopoly
she understood that the name of the game
is to acquire
she would accumulate everything she
could and eventually she became the
master of the board
and then she would always say the same
thing to me she'd look at me and she'd
say
one day you'll learn to play the game
one summer i played monopoly almost
every day all day long and that summer i
learned to play the game
i came to understand the only way to win
is to make a total commitment to
acquisition i came to understand that
money and possessions that's the way
that you keep score
and by the end of that summer i was more
ruthless than my grandmother i was ready
to bend the rules if i had to to win
that game
and i sat down with her to play that
fall
i took everything she had i watched her
give her last dollar and quit in utter
defeat
and then she had
one more thing to teach me
then she said
[Music]
now it all goes back in the box
all those houses and hotels
all the railroads and utility companies
all that property and all that wonderful
money
now it all goes back in the box
none of it was really yours
you got all heated up about it for a
while
but it was around a long time before you
sat down at the board
and it will be here after you're gone
players come and players go
houses and cars
titles and clothes
even your body
because the fact is that everything i
clutch and consume and hoard is going to
go back in the box and i'm going to lose
it all
you have to ask yourself when you
finally get the ultimate promotion when
you've made the ultimate purchase when
you buy the ultimate home when you have
stored up financial security and climb
the ladder of success to the highest
rung you can possibly climb it
and the thrill wears off
and it will wear off
then what
how far do you have to walk down that
road before you see where it leads
[Music]
surely you understand
it'll never be enough
[Music]
so you have to ask yourself the question
what matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
when i was a young man
growing up in new york city
i refused to pledge allegiance to the
flag
of course i was sent to the principal's
office
and he asked me why don't you want to
pledge allegiance everybody does
i said everybody once believed the earth
was flat but that doesn't make itself
i explained that america owed everything
it has to other cultures and other
nations and then i would rather pledge
allegiance to the earth
and everyone on it
needless to say it wasn't long before i
left school entirely
and i set up a lab in my bedroom
there i began to learn about science and
nature
i realized then that the universe is
governed by laws and that the human
being along with society itself was not
exempt from these laws
then came the crash of 1929
which began what we now call the great
depression
i found it difficult to understand why
millions were out of work homeless
starving while all the factories were
sitting there
the resources were unchanged
it was then that i realized that the
rules of the economic game were
inherently invalid
shortly after came world war ii
where various nations took turns
systematically destroying each other
i later calculated that all the
destruction and wasted resources spent
on that war could have easily provided
for every human need on the planet
since that time i have watched humanity
set the stage for its own extinction
i have watched as the precious finite
resources are perpetually wasted and
destroyed in the name of profit and free
markets
i have watched the social values of
society be reduced into a base
artificiality of materialism and
mindless consumption
and i have watched as the monetary
powers control the political structure
of supposedly free societies
i'm 94 years old now and i'm afraid my
disposition is the same as it was 75
years ago
this shit's got to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you're a scientist and somewhere along
the way hammered into your head is the
inevitable
nature versus nurture and that's at
least up there with coke versus pepsi or
greeks versus trojans so nature versus
nurture this by now
utterly oversimplifying view of
where
influences are influences on how a cell
deals with
an energy crisis up to what makes us who
we are in the most individualistic
levels of personality
and what you've got is this complete
false dichotomy built around
nature as deterministic at the very
bottom of all the causality of life as
dna and the code of codes and the holy
grail and everything is driven by it and
at the other end a much more social
science perspective which is we are
social organisms and biology is for
slime molds humans are free of biology
and
obviously both views are nonsense
what you see instead is it is virtually
impossible to understand how biology
works outside the context of environment
one of the most crazy making yet
widespread and potentially dangerous
notions is oh that behavior is genetic
now what does that mean it means all
sorts of subtle stuff if you sort of
know modern biology but for most people
out there what it winds up meaning is ah
a deterministic view of life one rooted
in biology and genetics genes equal
things that can't be changed genes equal
things that are inevitable and that you
might as well not waste resources trying
to fix might as well not put societal
energies into trying to improve because
it's inevitable it's unchangeable and
that is sheer nonsense
[Music]
it is widely thought that conditions
like adhd are genetically programmed
conditions like schizophrenia are
genetically programmed the truth is the
opposite nothing is genetically
programmed they're very rare diseases
i mean a small handful extremely
sparsely represented in a population
that are true truly genetically
determined
most complex conditions
might have a predisposition that is a
genetic component but a predisposition
is not the same as a predetermination
the whole search for the source of
diseases in the genome
was doomed to failure before anybody
even thought of it because most diseases
are not genetically predetermined
heart disease cancer strokes
rheumatoid conditions autoimmune
conditions in general
mental health conditions addictions
these are none of them genetically
determined
breast cancer for example out of 100
women with breast cancer
only seven will carry the breast cancer
genes 93 do not
and out of 100 women who do have the
genes not all of them will get cancer
[Music]
genes are not just things that make us
behave in a particular way regardless of
our environment
genes give us different ways of
responding to our environment
and
in fact it looks as if some of the early
childhood influences of a kind of child
rearing
affects gene expression actually turning
on and off different genes
to put you on a different development
developmental track which may suit the
kind of world you've got to deal with
so for example
a study done in montreal with suicide
victims
looked at autopsies of the brains of
these people
and it turned out that if a suicide
victim these are usually young adults
had been abused as children the abuse
actually caused the genetic change in
the brain
that was absent in the brains of people
who had not been abused
that's an epigenetic effect epi means on
top of so that so that the epigenetic
influence
is what happens environmentally
to either
activate or deactivate certain genes
in new zealand there's a study that was
done in a town called dunedin
in which
a few thousand individuals were studied
from birth up to their into their
twenties
what they found was
that
they could identify
a genetic mutation an abnormal gene
which did have some relation to the
predisposition to commit violence
but only if the individual had also
been subjected to severe child abuse
in other words a child with this
abnormal gene would be no more likely to
be violent than anybody else and in fact
they actually had a lower rate of
violence than people with normal genes
as long as they weren't abused as
children
great additional example of the ways in
which genes are not be all and all fancy
technique where you can take a specific
gene out of a mouse that mouse and this
descendants will not have that gene you
have knocked out that gene so there's
this one gene that codes for a protein
that has something to do with learning
and memory and this fabulous
demonstration knock out that gene and
you have a mouse that doesn't learn as
well oh a genetic basis for intelligence
what was much less appreciated in that
landmark study that got picked up by the
media left and right is take those
genetically impaired mice and raise them
in a much more enriched stimulating
environment than your normal mice in a
lab cage and they completely overcame
that deficit
so
when one says in the contemporary sense
that oh this behavior is genetic
to the extent that that's even a valid
sort of phrase to use what you're saying
is there is a genetic contribution to
how this organism responds to
environment
genes may influence the
readiness with which an organism will
deal with a certain environmental
challenge you know that's not the
version most people have in their minds
and not to be too soapboxing but run
with the old
sort of version of its genetic and it's
not that far from a history of eugenics
and things of that sort
it's a widespread misconception it's
potentially a fairly dangerous one
one reason that the
sort of biological explanation for
violence one reason that hypothesis is
potentially dangerous it's not just
misleading it can really do harm
is because
if you believe that
you could very easily say well there's
nothing we can do to change the
predisposition people have to becoming
violent all we can do if somebody
becomes violent is punish them you know
lock them up or execute them but we
don't need to worry about changing the
social environment or the social
preconditions
that may lead people to become violent
because
that's irrelevant
the genetic argument allows us the
luxury of ignoring
past and present historical and social
factors and in the words of louis
maynard he wrote in the new yorker very
astutely said it's all in the genes
an explanation for the way things are
that does not threaten the way things
are why should someone feel unhappy
or engage in antisocial behavior when
that person is living in the freeest and
most
prosperous nation on earth it can't be
the system
there must be a flaw in the wiring
somewhere
which is a good way of putting it so the
genetic argument is simply a cop-out
which allows us to ignore
the social and economic and political
factors that in fact underlie
many
troublesome behaviors
[Music]
addictions are usually
considered to be a drug related issue
but looking at more broadly i define
addiction as any behavior
that is associated with
craving with temporary relief
and with long-term negative consequences
along with an impairment of control over
it so that the person
wishes to give her give it up or
promises to do so
but can't follow through
and when you understand that then you
can see that
there are many more addictions than
simply those related to drugs there's
workaholism it's
addiction to shopping to the internet to
video games
there's the addiction to power people
that have power but they want more and
more and more nothing is ever enough for
them uh acquisition corporations that
must own more and more
the addiction to oil but at least to the
wealth and to the products made
accessible to us by oil
look at the negative consequences on the
environment
uh now very we're destroying the very
earth that we
inhabit
for the sake of that addiction now these
addictions are far more devastating in
the social consequences
than the cocaine or heroin habits of my
downtiny side patients
yet they're rewarded
and considered to be respectable
the tobacco company executive that shows
a higher profit will get a much bigger
reward
he doesn't face any negative
consequences legally or otherwise in
fact he's a respected member of the
board of several other
corporations but tobacco smoke related
diseases kill
five and a half million people around
the world every year
in the united states they kill 400 000
people a year
and these people are addicted to what to
profit to such a degree are they
addicted that they're actually in denial
about the impact of their
activities which is typical for addicts
it's denial
and that's a respectable one it's
respectable to be addicted to profit no
matter what the cost
so what is acceptable and what is
respectable is a highly arbitrary
phenomenon in our society and it seems
like the greater the harm the more
respectable the addiction
there's a general myth that drugs in
themselves are addictive in fact the war
on drugs is predicated on the idea that
if you interdict the sources of drugs
you can deal with addiction that way
now
if we understand addiction in a broader
sense we see that nothing in itself is
addictive no substance no drug is it by
itself addictive and no behavior is by
itself addictive many people can go
shopping without becoming shopaholics
not everybody becomes a food addict not
everyone who drinks a glass of wine
becomes an alcoholic so the real issue
is what makes people susceptible because
it's the combination of a susceptible
individual
and the potentially addictive substance
or behavior that actually that makes for
the
for full flowering of addiction
in short it's not the drug that's
addictive it's the question of the
susceptibility individual to being
addicted to particular substance or
behavior
if we wish to understand what that makes
us some people susceptible we actually
have to look at the life experience
the uh
old idea although it's old but it's
still
broadly held that addictions are due to
some genetic cause is simply
scientifically untenable
what the case is actually is that
certain life experiences make people
susceptible
life experiences that not only shape the
person's
personality and and psychological needs
but also their very brains in certain
ways and that process begins in utero
[Music]
it's been shown for example that if you
stress mothers during pregnancy
their children are more likely to have
traits that predispose them to
addictions
and that's because uh development is
shaped by the psychological and social
environment so the biology of human
beings is very much affected by and
programmed by their life experiences
beginning in utero
environment does not begin at birth
environment begins as soon as you have
an environment as soon as your fetus you
are subject to whatever information is
coming through moms circulations
hormones levels of nutrients
great landmark example of this something
called the dutch hunger winter
1944 nazis occupying holland for a bunch
of reasons they decide to take all the
food and divert it to germany for three
months everybody there is starving tens
of thousands of people starved to death
what the dutch hunger winter effect is
if you were a second or third trimester
fetus during the starvation your body
learned something very unique during
that time as it turns out second third
trimester something that your body is
going about trying to learn about the
environment is well how
menacing of the place is it out there
how plentiful how how much nutrients am
i getting by way of mom's circulation be
a fetus who is starving during that time
and your body programs forever after to
be really really really stingy with your
sugar and fat and and what you do is you
store every bit of it be a dutch hunger
winter fetus and half a century later
everything else being equal you are more
likely to have high blood pressure
obesity or metabolic syndrome that is
environment coming in a very unexpected
place
you can stress animals in a laboratory
when they're pregnant and their
offspring will be more likely to use
cocaine and alcohol as adults
you can stress human mothers for example
in a british study
women who are abused in pregnancy
will have higher levels of the
stress form on cortisol in their
placenta at birth and their children are
more likely to have conditions that
predispose them to addictions by age
seven or eight
so any lower stress uh already prepares
the ground for all kinds of mental
health issues
israeli study done prior
on children born to mothers who were
pregnant prior to the onset of the 1967
war
uh
these women of course are very stressed
and their offspring have a higher
incidence of schizophrenia
than the average cohort
so there's plenty of evidence now that
prenatal effects have a huge impact on
the developing human being
the point about human development and
specifically human brain development is
that it occurs mostly under the impact
of the environment and mostly after
birth
now if you compare us to a horse
which can run on the first day of life
we see that we are very undeveloped we
can't develop we can't
muster that much neurological
coordination balance muscle strength
visual acuity until year and a half two
years and that's because the brain
development that in the horse happens in
the safety of the womb and a human being
has to happen
after birth and that has to do with
simple evolutionary logic as the head
gets larger which is what makes us into
human beings the
virginity of the forebrain is what
creates the human species actually
at the same time you walk on two legs so
our pelvis narrows to accommodate that
so now we have a narrower pelvis a
larger head bingo we have to be born
prematurely and that means that the
brain development that in other animals
occurs in euro in us occurs after birth
and much of that under the impact of the
environment and
the concept of neural darwinism simply
means that the circuits that get the
appropriate input from the environment
will develop optimally and the ones that
don't will either not develop optimally
or perhaps not at all if you take a
child with perfectly good eyes at birth
and you put him in a dark room for five
years he'll be blind thereafter for the
rest of his life because the circuits of
vision require light waves for their
development and without that even the
rudimentary circuits present and active
at birth will atrophy and die and new
ones will not develop
there's a significant way in which early
experiences
shape adult behavior
and even and especially early
experiences for which there's no recall
memory
it turns out that there are two kinds of
memory there is explicit memory which is
recall this is when you can call back
facts details episodes
circumstances
but the structure in the brain which is
called the hippocampus which encodes
recall memory it doesn't even begin to
develop fully until a year and a half
and it's not fully developed or much
later which is why hardly anybody has
any recall memory prior to 18 months
but there's another kind of memory which
is called the implicit memory which is
in fact an emotional memory
where the emotional impact and the
interpretation that the child makes of
those emotional experiences is ingrained
in the brain in the form of nerve
circuits ready to fire without specific
recall so give you a clear example
people who are adopted have a lifelong
sense of rejection very often
they can't recall the adoption they
can't recall the separation of a birth
mother there's nothing there to recall
with but the emotional memory of
separation and rejection is deeply
embedded in their brains hence they're
much more likely to experience a sense
of rejection and a great emotional upset
when they perceive themselves as being
rejected than other people that's not
unique to people who are adopted but
it's particularly strong in them because
of this function of implicit memory
people who are addicted
given that they
according to all the research literature
certainly in my experience the hardcore
addicts
virtually were all
significantly abused these children or
suffered severe emotional loss their
emotional or implicit memories are those
of a world that's not safe and not not
helpful caregivers who are not to be
trusted
and relationships that are
not uh safe enough to open up to
vulnerably and hence their responses
tend to be to keep themselves separate
from really intimate relationships uh
not to trust caregivers
doctors and other people who are trying
to help them and generally see the world
as an unsafe place and that's
strictly a function of implicit memory
which sometimes has to do with incidents
they don't even recall
[Music]
infants were born premature are often in
incubators and various types of gadgetry
and machinery for weeks and perhaps
months
it's not known that if these children
are touched and stroked on the back for
just 10 minutes a day that promotes
their brain development
so human touch is essential for
development and in fact infants whenever
picked up will actually die
that how much of a fundamental need
being held is to human beings
in our society there's an unfortunate
tendency to tell parents not to pick up
their kids not to hold them not to
pick up babies who are crying for fear
of spoiling them or
to to encourage them to sleep to the
night you don't pick them up which is
just the opposite of what the child
needs and these children might go back
to sleep because they give up
and their brains just shut down as a way
of
defending against the vulnerability of
being abandoned really by their parents
but their implicit memories will be that
of a world that doesn't give a damn
a lot of these differences
are structured very early in life
in a way the if you like the parental
experience of adversity
how tough life is or how easy it is is
passed on to children whether through
maternal depression or parents being bad
tempered with their kids because they've
had a hard day or just being too tired
at the end of the day
and these have very powerful effects uh
programming children's development which
we know a lot about now
but that's early sensitivity isn't just
an evolutionary mistake
it exists again in many different
species even seedlings is an early
adaptive process to the kind of
environment they're growing up in but
for humans
the adaptation is to the quality of
social relations
and so
uh early life how nurturing or how much
conflict how much attention you get
is a taster
of the kind of world you may be growing
up in are you growing up in a world
where you have to fight for what you can
get watch your back fend for yourself
learn not to trust others
why are you growing up in a society
where you depend on reciprocity
mutuality cooperation where empathy is
important where your security depends on
good relations with other people
and that needs a very different
emotional and cognitive development and
that's what the early sensitivity is
about
and
parenting is almost
quite unconsciously a system for passing
on that experience to children the kind
of world they're in
the great british child psychiatrist dw
winnicott said that fundamentally two
things can go wrong in childhood one is
when things happen that shouldn't happen
and then things that should happen but
don't
and the first category is the traumatic
and abusive
and abandonment experiences of my
downtown eastside patients and of many
addicts
that's what shouldn't happen but did
but then there is the
non-stressed attuned non-distracted
attention of the parent that every child
needs
that very often children don't get
they're not abused they're not neglected
and and they're not traumatized
but what should happen
the presence of the emotionally
available nurturing plant just is not
available to them because of the
stresses in our society and the
parenting environment and the
psychologist
alan shore calls that proximal
abandonment when the present the parent
is physically present
but emotionally absent
i have spent
roughly the last 40 years of my life
working with the most violent
people our society produces murderers
rapists and so on
in an attempt to understand what causes
this violence
i discovered that the most violent of
the criminals in our prisons
had themselves been victims
of a degree of child abuse that was
beyond the scale of what i ever thought
of applying the term child abuse to i
had no idea
of the depth
of the depravity with which children in
our society are all too often treated
the most violent people i saw were
themselves the survivors of their own
attempted murder often at the hands of
their parents or other people in their
social environment or where the
survivors of family members have been
killed
their closest family members by by other
people
the buddha argued
that everything depends on everything
else he says the one contains the many
and the many contains the one that you
can't understand anything
in isolation from its environment the
leaf contains the sun the sky and the
earth obviously
uh
this has not been shown to be true of
course all around and specifically when
it comes to human development
the modern scientific term for it is the
biopsychosocial nature of human
development which says that the biology
of human beings depends very much on
their interaction with the social and
psychological environment and
specifically the
psychiatrist and researcher
daniel siegel at university of
california los angeles ucla is coined
the phrase interpersonal neurobiology
which means to say that the
way that our nervous system functions
depends very much on our personal
relationships
in the first place with the parenting
caregivers and in the second place with
other important attachment figures in
our lives and in the third place with
our entire culture so that you can't
separate
the
neurological functioning of a human
being from the environment in which he
or she grew up in and continues to exist
in
and
this is true throughout the life cycle
it's particularly true when you're
dependent and helpless and your brain is
developing but it's too even in adults
and even at the end of life
[Music]
human beings have lived in almost every
kind of society from
the most egalitarian hunting and
gathering societies seem to have been
very egalitarian for instance based on
food sharing gift exchange
small bands of people living
predominantly off of foraging
but a little bit of hunting
predominantly among people you have at
the least known your entire life if not
surrounded by third cousins or closer in
a world in which there is a great deal
of fluidity between different groups in
a world in which there is not a whole
lot in terms of material culture this is
how humans have spent most of their
hominin history and
no surprise that makes for a very
different world one of the things you
get as a result of that is
far less violence
organized group violence is not
something that occurred at that time of
human history and it seems quite clear
so where did we go wrong
violence is not
uh
universal it's not symmetrically
distributed throughout the human race
there is a huge variation in the amount
of violence in different societies there
are some societies that have
virtually no violence there are others
that
destroy themselves some of the
anabaptist
religious groups that are complete
strict pacifists like the amish the
mennonites the hutterites among some of
these groups the hutterites
there are no recorded cases of homicide
um
uh during uh
our major wars like world war ii where
people were being drafted they would
refuse to serve in the military they
would go to prison rather than serving
the military in the kubutsu in israel
the level of violence is so low that the
criminal courts there
will often send
violent offenders people have committed
crimes to live on the kibbutzim in order
to learn how to live a non-violent life
because that's the way people live there
so we are amply shaped by society our
societies in the broader sense including
our theological or metaphysical our
linguistic influences etc our societies
help shape us as to whether or not we
think
life is basically about sin or about
beauty whether the afterlife will carry
a price for how we live our lives or if
it's irrelevant
in a broad sort of way different large
societies could be termed as
individualistic or collectivist and you
get very different people in different
mindsets and i suspect different brains
coming along with that we in america are
in one of the most individualistic of
societies and
capitalism being a system that allows
you to go higher and higher up a
potential pyramid and the deal is it
comes with fewer and fewer safety nets
by definition the more stratified a
society is the fewer people you have as
peers the fewer people with whom you
have symmetrical reciprocal
relationships and instead all you have
are differing spots and endless
hierarchies and a world in which you
have few reciprocal partners as a world
with a lot less altruism
all right so this brings us to a total
impossible juncture which is
to try to make sense and
perspective science as to what the
nature is of human nature
you know on a certain level
the nature of our nature is not to be
particularly constrained by our nature
we come up with more social variability
than any species out there more systems
of belief of styles of family structures
of ways of raising children the capacity
for variety that we have is
extraordinary
in a society which is predicated on
competition
and
really
very often the ruthless exploitation
of one human being by another
the profiteering of other people's
problems
and very often
the creation of problems for the purpose
of profiteering
the ruling ideology will very often
justify that behavior by appeals to some
fundamental and unalterable human nature
so the myth in our society is that
people are competitive by nature and
that they're individualistic and that
they're selfish
the real uh reality is quite the
opposite we have certain human needs the
only way that you can talk about human
nature concretely is by recognizing that
there's certain human needs we have a
human need for companionship and for
close contact to be loved to be attached
to to be accepted to be seen to be
received for who we are
if those needs are met we develop into
people who are compassionate
and cooperative
and um and who have empathy for other
people
so
the opposite that we often see in our
society is in fact the distortion of
human nature precisely because so few
people have their needs met
so yes you can talk about human nature
but only in the sense of basic human
needs
that are instinctively evoked or i
should say certain human needs
that lead to certain traits if they are
met in a different set of traits if
they're denied
so
when we recognize the fact that the
human organism which has a great deal of
adaptive flexibility allowing us to
survive in many different conditions
is also rigidly programmed for certain
environmental requirements or
human needs
a social imperative begins to emerge
just as our bodies require physical
nutrients the human brain demands
positive forms of environmental stimulus
at all stages of development
while also needing to be protected from
other negative forms of stimulus
and if things that should happen do not
or things that shouldn't happen do
it is now apparent that the door can be
opened for not only a cascade of mental
and physical diseases
but many detrimental human behaviors as
well
so as we turn our perspective now
outward and take account for the state
of affairs today
we must ask the question
is the condition we have created in the
modern world actually supporting our
health
is the bedrock of our socioeconomic
system acting as a positive force for
human and social development and
progress
or
is the foundational gravitation of our
society
actually going against the core
evolutionary requirements
needed to create and maintain our
personal and social well-being
so
so one might ask where did this all
begin
what we have today really a world in a
state of cumulative collapse
you get it started with john locke
and john locke introduces property and
has three provisals for just private
right and property
and the three provisals are that there
must be enough left over for others and
that you must not let it spoil and that
you most of all must mix your labor with
it
it seems justified you mix your labor
with the world then you're entitled to
the product and as long as there's
enough left over for others uh and as
long as it doesn't spoil you don't allow
anything to go to waste that's okay well
he spends a long time of his famous
treatise of government and it's since
been the canonical text for economic and
political and legal understanding is
still at the classic texas study
well what he did is it after he gives
the provisals and you're almost thinking
at the time whether you're for private
property or not he's given a very a very
good and plausible and powerful defense
of private property here well he drops
them he drops them like that right in
one sentence he says well once the
introduction of money came in by men's
tacit consent then it became and he
doesn't say all the provisos are
cancelled erased but that's what happens
so now we have not product in your
property earned by your own labor oh no
money buys labor now
there's no longer consideration of
whether there's enough left over for
others there's no longer a consideration
of whether it spoils because he says
well money's like silver and gold and
gold can't spoil therefore monies can't
be
responsible for waste which is
ridiculous we're not talking about money
and silver we're talking about what its
effects are it's one non-sequitur after
another just the most uh startling uh
logical ledger domain that he gets away
with here but it fits the interests of
capital owners
then adam smith comes along and what he
adds is the religion to this lock
started with god made it all this way
this is god's right and now we get also
with smith coming along he says it's not
only god's i mean he's not saying this
but this is what's happening
philosophically in principle he's saying
it's not only question of private
property that's all now presupposed is
given
and that there's money investors that
buy labor given that there's no limit to
how much they can buy of other men's
labor how much they can accumulate how
much inequality that's all given though
and so he comes along and what his big
idea is and again it's just introduced
in in parenthesis
on passang
you know when people put out the goods
for sale and others you know the supply
and other people buy them with the
demand and so forth how do you how do we
have
supply equaling demand and demand
equaling supply how can they come into
equilibrium and that is one of the
central notions of economics is how do
they come into equilibrium
and he says it's the invisible hand of
the market that brings them into
equilibrium so now we have god is
actually imminent he just didn't give
the rights to property and how uh you
know all its wherewithal and its natural
rights of doing all that log said now we
have the system itself as god
in fact smith says
when he talks and you'll never find this
quoted you'll have to read the whole of
the
inquiry into the wealth of nations he
says the scantiness of subsistence sets
limits
to the reproduction of the poor and that
nature can deal with this in no other
way than elimination of their children
so he anticipated evolutionary theory in
the worst sense i applied hid this as
well before darwin and so he he called
them the race of laborers
so you can see there was inherent racism
built in here there was an
inherent acceptance life blindness to
kill
innumerable children
and he thought well that's the invisible
hand making supply meet demand and
demand meet supply so see what how wise
god is
so you can see a lot of the really very
this life-destructive
eco-genocidal things that are going on
now have in a way a thought gene
back in smith 2.
when we reflect on the original concept
of the so-called free-market capitalist
system as initiated by early economic
philosophers such as adam smith we see
that the original intent of a market was
based around real tangible
life-supporting goods for trade
adam smith never fathomed that the most
profitable economic sector on the planet
would eventually be in the arena of
financial trading or so-called
investment
where money itself is simply gained by
the movement of other money in an
arbitrary game which holds zero
productive merit to society
yet regardless of smith's intent the
door for such seemingly anomalous
advents was left wide open by one
fundamental tenet of this theory
money is treated as a commodity
in and of itself
today in every economy of the world
regardless of the social system they
claim
money is pursued for the sake of money
and nothing else
the underlying idea which was
mysteriously qualified by adam smith
with his religious declaration of the
invisible hand
is that the narrow self-interested
pursuit of this fictional commodity will
somehow magically manifest human and
social well-being and progress
the reality is that the monetary
incentive interest or what some have
termed the money sequence of value has
now completely decoupled from the
foundational life interest which could
be termed the life sequence of value
what has happened is that there's a
complete confusion in economic doctrine
between those two sequences they think
that the money sequence of value
delivers the life sequence of value that
and that's why they say if more goods
are sold if gdps rise and so forth
therefore there'll be more well-being
enhanced well-being we take the gdp to
be a basic layer indicator of social
health well there you see the confusion
it's talking about money sequences of
value that is all the receipts all the
revenues that are derived from selling
uh goods
and they're confusing that with life
reproduction so that you have built
right into this thing from the beginning
is a complete conflation of the money
and life sequences of value so we're
dealing with a kind of structured
delusion that becomes more and more
deadly as the money sequence decouples
from producing anything at all
so it's a system disorder and the system
disorder seems to be fatal
in society today you seldom hear anyone
speak of the progress of their country
or society in terms of their physical
well-being state of happiness trust or
social stability
rather the measures are presented to us
through economic abstractions
we have the gross domestic product the
consumer price index the value of the
stock market rates of inflation and so
on
but does this tell us anything of real
value as to the quality of people's
lives
no all these measures have to do with
the money sequence itself and nothing
more
for example the gross domestic product
of a country is a measure of the value
of goods and services sold
this measure is claimed to correlate to
the standard of living of a country's
people
in the united states health care
accounted for over 17 percent of gdp in
2009 amounting to over 2.5 trillion
spent hence creating a positive effect
on this economic measure
and based on this logic it would be even
better for the us economy if health care
services increased more so perhaps to
three trillion dollars or five trillion
since that would create more growth more
jobs and hence boasted by economists as
a rise in their country's standard of
living
but wait a minute what do health care
services actually represent
well
sick and dying people
that's right the more unhealthy people
there are in america the better the
economy
now that is not an exaggeration or a
cynical perspective in fact if we step
back far enough you will realize that
the gdp not only doesn't reflect real
public or social health on any tangible
level
it is in fact mostly a measure of
industrial inefficiency and social
degradation
and the more you see it rise the worse
things are becoming with respect to
personal
social and environmental integrity
you have to create problems to create
profit
there is no profit under the current
paradigm
in saving lives putting balance on this
planet having justice and peace or
anything else there's just no profit
there
[Music]
there's an old saying pass a law create
a business
whether you're creating a business for a
lawyer or whatever
so you know crime does create business
just like destruction creates creates
business in haiti we have now roughly
two million people incarcerated in this
country and of those many of them are in
prisons run by private corporations
corrections corporation of america
whacking out who trade their stock on
wall street based upon how many people
are in jail
now that's sickness but that is a
reflection of what this economic
paradigm calls for
so what exactly does this economic
paradigm call for
what is it that keeps our economic
system going
consumption
or more accurately cyclical consumption
when we break down the foundation of
classic market economics we are left
with a pattern of monetary exchange that
simply cannot be allowed to stop or even
substantially slowed if the society as
we know it is to remain operational
there are three main actors on the
economic stage the employee the employer
and the consumer
the employee sells labor to the employer
for income
the employer sells its production
services and hence goods to the consumer
for income and the consumer of course is
simply another role of the employer and
employee spending back into the system
to enable the cyclical consumption to
continue
in other words the global market system
is based on the assumption that there
will always be enough product demand in
society to move enough money around at a
rate which can keep the consumption
process going and the faster the rate of
consumption the more so-called economic
growth is assumed and so the machine
goes
but hold on
i thought an economy was meant to i
don't know
economize
doesn't the very term have to do with
preservation and efficiency and a
reduction of waste
so how does our system which demands
consumption and the more the better
efficiently preserve or economize at all
well it doesn't
the intent of the market system is in
fact the exact opposite of what a real
economy is supposed to do
which is efficiently and conservatively
orient the materials for production and
distribution of life-supporting goods
we live on a finite planet with finite
resources where for example the oil we
utilize took millions of years to
develop
where the minerals we use took billions
of years to develop
so
having a system that deliberately
promotes the acceleration of consumption
for the sake of so-called economic
growth is pure
ecocidal insanity
absence of waste that's what efficiency
is
absence of waste
this system is more wasteful than all
the other existing systems in the
history of the planet
every level of life organization and
life system is in a state of crisis and
challenge and decay or collapse no
peer-reviewed journal in the last 30
years
will tell you anything different that is
that every life system is in decline as
well as social programs as well as our
water access try to name any means of
life that isn't threatened and in danger
you can't there isn't there really isn't
one and that's very very despairing but
we haven't even figured out the causal
mechanism we don't want to face the
causal mechanism we just want to go on
you know that's what insanity is where
you keep doing the same thing over and
over again though it clearly doesn't
work
so you're really
dealing with not an economic system but
i would go so far as to say an
anti-economic system
[Music]
there's an old saying that the
competitive market model seeks to create
the best possible goods at the lowest
possible prices
this statement is essentially the
incentive concept which justifies market
competition based on the assumption that
the result is the production of higher
quality goods
if i was going to build myself a table
from scratch i would naturally build it
out of the best most durable materials
possible right with the intent for it to
last as long as possible
why would i want to make something poor
knowing i would have to eventually do it
again and expend more materials and more
energy
well as rational as that may seem in the
physical world when it comes to the
market world it is not only explicitly
irrational it is not even an option
it is technically impossible to produce
the best of anything if a company is to
maintain a competitive edge and hence
remain affordable to the consumer
literally everything created and set for
sale in the global economy is
immediately inferior the moment it is
produced for it is a mathematical
impossibility to make the most
scientifically advanced efficient and
strategically sustainable products
this is due to the fact that the market
system requires that cost efficiency or
the need to reduce expenses exist at
every stage of production from the cost
of labor to the cost of materials and
packaging and so on
this competitive strategy of course is
to make sure the public buys their goods
rather than from a competing producer
which is doing the exact same thing to
also make their goods both competitive
and affordable
this immutably wasteful consequence of
the system could be termed intrinsic
obsolescence
however this is only one part of a
larger problem
a fundamental governing principle of
market economics one that you will not
find in any textbook by the way
is the following
nothing produced can be allowed to
maintain a lifespan longer than what can
be endured in order to continue cyclical
consumption
in other words it is critical that stuff
break down fail and expire within a
certain amount of time
this is termed planned obsolescence
planned obsolescence is the backbone of
the underlying market strategy of every
goods producing corporation in existence
while a very few of course would admit
to such a strategy outright what they do
is mask it within the intrinsic
obsolescence phenomenon just discussed
while often ignoring or even suppressing
new advents and technology which might
create a more sustainable durable good
so if it wasn't wasteful enough that the
system inherently cannot allow the most
durable and efficient goods to be
produced planned obsolescence
deliberately recognizes that the longer
any good is in operation the worse it is
for sustaining cyclical consumption and
hence the market system itself
in other words product sustainability is
actually inverse to economic growth and
hence there is a direct
reinforced incentive to make sure
lifespans are short of any given good
produced
and in fact the system cannot operate
any other way
one glance at the sea of landfills now
spreading across the world showed the
obsolescence reality
there are now billions of cheaply made
cell phones computers and other
technology each full of precious
difficult to mine materials such as gold
coltan copper now rotting in vast piles
usually due to the mirror malfunction or
obsolescence of small parts
which in a conservative society could
likely be fixed or updated and the life
of the good extended
unfortunately as efficient as that may
seem in our physical reality living on a
finite planet with finite resources
it is explicitly inefficient with
respect to the market
to put it into a phrase efficiency
sustainability and preservation
are the enemies of our economic system
likewise just as physical goods need to
be constantly produced and reproduced
regardless of their environmental impact
the service industry operates with an
equal rationale
the fact is there is no monetary benefit
to resolving any problems which are
currently being serviced
at the end of the day the last thing the
medical establishment really wants is
the curing of diseases such as cancer
which would eliminate countless jobs and
trillions in revenue
and since we're on the subject crime and
terrorism in this system are good
well at least economically ford is
employing police generating high-value
commodities for security not to mention
the value of prisons that are privately
owned for profit
and how about war
the war industry in america is a huge
driver of gdp one of the most profitable
industries producing weapons of death
and destruction
the favorite game of this industry is to
blow things up and then go and rebuild
them for profit we saw this with the
windfall billion dollar contracts made
from the iraq war
the bottom line is that socially
negative attributes of society have
become positively rewarded ventures for
industry and any interest in problem
resolution or environmental
sustainability and conservation is
intrinsically counter to economic
sustainability
and this is why every time you see the
gdp rise in any country you are
witnessing an increase in necessity
whether real or contrived and by
definition a necessity is rooted in
inefficiency
hence increased necessity means
increased inefficiency
[Music]
the american dream is based on rampant
consumerism it is based upon the fact
that mainstream media and especially
commercial advertising
uh all corporations who need this
infinite growth have convinced us or
brainwashed
most people in america and hence the
world that we have to have x number of
material possessions and the possibility
of gaining infinitely more material
possessions in order to be happy that's
just not true
so how why do people continue to to buy
in this way which is ultimately
co-genocidal in its systemic effects
cumulatively and it just is classical
operant conditioning you simply put
inputs of conditioning into the organism
and you have outputs of desired
behaviors or goals or objectives
and it has all the resources of
technology and they post about how they
get into the minds of infants what they
hear
is already making them conditioned to
the brand
then you see well that's how
people have been such fools in a way
they've been taught to be fools it's a
value system disorder
you know if there is any testament to
the plasticity of the human mind if
there is any proof to how malleable
human thought is and how easily
conditioned and guided people can become
based on the nature of their
environmental stimulus and what it
reinforces
the world of commercial advertising is
the proof
you have to stand in awe
at the level of brainwashing where these
programmed robots known as consumers
wander the landscape only to walk into a
store and spend say
four thousand dollars on a handbag that
likely costs ten dollars to make in a
sweatshop overseas only for the brand
status it supposedly represents in the
culture
or perhaps the ancient communal
traditions which increase trust and
cohesiveness in society which have now
been hijacked by acquisitive
materialistic values where now annually
we exchange useless crap a few times a
year
and we might wonder why so many today
have a compulsion to shopping and
acquisition when it is clear that they
have been conditioned from childhood to
expect material goods as a sign of their
status with friends and family
the fact is the foundation of any
society are the values that support its
operation and our society as it exists
can only operate if our values support
the conspicuous consumption it requires
to continue the market system
75 years ago consumption in america and
much of the first world was half of what
we see today per person
today's new consumer culture has been
manufactured and imposed due to the very
real need for higher and higher levels
of consumption
and this is why most corporations now
spend more money on advertising than the
actual process of product creation
itself
they work diligently to create a false
need for you to fill
and it happens to work
you know economists are in fact not
economists at all they're propagandists
of money value and you'll find that all
their models basically get down to token
exchanges that are to the profit
of one side or both sides or whatever
but they're completely disconnected from
the actually existing world of
reproduction and in ohio
an old man failed to pay his electric
bill you may be familiar with the case
and the electric company turned off the
electricity and he died the reason they
turned it off was because it wouldn't
have been profitable for them to keep it
on because he didn't pay his bill
do you believe that was right
the responsibility really lies not on
the electric company for turning it off
but on those of this man's neighbors and
friends
and associates who are not charitable
enough to enable him as an individual
to meet the electric bill
hmm
did i hear that right did he just say
the death of a man caused by not having
money was the responsibility of other
people or in effect charity
well then i guess we're going to need a
whole lot of infomercials a little
miserable coin slot donations for bodega
counters
and a bunch of pickle jars for the
billion people now starving to death on
this planet because of the very system
milton friedman promotes
whether you are dealing with the
philosophies of milton friedman fa hayek
john maynard keynes ludwig von mises or
any other major market economist the
basis of rationale rarely leaves the
money sequence it is like a religion
consumption analysis stabilization
policies deficit spending aggregate
demand
it exists as a never-ending
self-referring
self-rationalizing circle of discourse
where universal human need
natural resources or any form of
physical life supporting efficiency is
ruled out by default and replaced by the
singular notion that humans seeking
advantage over each other for money
alone motivated by their own narrow
self-interest will magically create a
sustainable healthy balanced society
there is no life coordinate in this
whole theory this whole doctrine what
are they doing what are they doing what
they're doing is tracking money
sequences that's all it is is tracking
money sequences presupposing
everything that matters one that there's
no life coordinates
no life coordinates
two that all the agents are
self-maximizing preference seekers
that is they think of nothing other than
themselves and what they can get most
for themselves that that note that
seduction that's the ruling notion of
rationality
self-maximizing choice and and the only
thing that they're interested in
self-maximizing is money or commodities
well where does social relations come in
it doesn't accept in the exchange to
self-maximize
where do our natural resources come in
they don't accept to
exploit
where
does the family come in as being able to
survive it doesn't
they have to have money in order to
purchase any
good well shouldn't an economy deal
somehow with human need isn't that what
the full fundamental issue is to satisfy
our human needs oh need isn't even in
your lexicon uh you dissolve it into
once and what does it want that means
money demand that wants to buy
well if it's money when the man that
wants to buy it's got nothing to do with
need because it may be the person has no
money demand and desperately needs to
say water supply
or it may be money to man wants a gold
toilet seat well where does it all go to
the gold toilet seat and you call this
economics like it's really when one
thinks of it it's got to be the most
bizarre
uh
delusion in the history of human thought
[Music]
now so far we have focused on the market
system but this system is actually only
one half of the global economic paradigm
the other half is the monetary system
while the market system deals with the
interaction of people gaming for profit
across the spectrum of labor
production and distribution
the monetary system is an underlying set
of policies set by financial
institutions which create conditions for
the market system among other things
it includes terms we often hear such as
interest rates loans debt the money
supply inflation etc
and while you might want to pull your
hair out listening to the gibberish
coming from the monetary economists
modest preemptive actions can obviate
the need of more drastic actions at a
later date the nature and effect of this
system is actually quite simple
our economy has
or the global economy has three basic
things a governor one is fractional
reserve banking but bank's printing
money out of nothing
it's also based upon compound interest
when you borrow money you have to pay
back more than you borrowed which means
that you in effect create money
out of thin air again which has to be
serviced by creating still more money
we live in an infinite growth paradigm
the economic paradigm we live in now is
is a ponzi scheme it's nothing grows
forever it's not possible as a great
psychologist james hillman wrote the
only thing that grows in a human body
after a certain age is cancer
it's not just the amount of money that
has to keep growing it's the amount of
consumers consumers to borrow money at
interest to generate more money and
obviously that's not possible on a
finite planet
people are basically vehicles to just
create money which must create more
money to keep the whole thing from
falling apart which is what's happening
right now
there are really only two things anyone
needs to know about the monetary system
one
all money is created out of debt
money is monetized debt whether it
materialized from treasury bonds home
loan contracts or credit cards
in other words if all outstanding debt
was to be repaid right now there would
not be one dollar in circulation
and two
interest is charged on virtually all
loans made
and the money needed to pay back this
interest does not exist in the money
supply outright
only the principle is created by the
loans and the principle is the money
supply
so if all this debt was to be repaid
right now not only would there not be
one dollar left in circulation there
would also be a gigantic amount of money
owed that is literally impossible to pay
back for it does not exist
the consequence of all of this is that
two things are inevitable
inflation
and bankruptcy
as far as inflation this can be seen as
a historical trend in virtually every
country today and easily tied to its
cause which is the perpetual increase of
the money supply which is required to
cover the interest charges and keep the
system going
as far as bankruptcy it comes in the
form of debt collapse
this collapse will inevitably occur with
a person a business or a country and
typically happens when the interest
payments are no longer possible to make
but there is a bright side to all of
this well
at least in terms of the market system
because debt creates pressure
debt creates wage slaves
a person in debt is much more likely to
take a low wage than a person who isn't
hence becoming a cheap commodity
so it's great for the corporations to
have a pool of people that have no
financial mobility
but hey that same train of thought also
goes for entire countries the world bank
and the international monetary fund
which mostly serve as proxies for
transnational corporate interests
give gigantic loans to troubled
countries at very high interest rates
and then once the countries are deeply
in the hole and can't pay austerity
measures are applied the corporations
swoop in set up sweatshops and take
their natural resources
now that's market efficiency
but wait there's more
you see there's this unique hybrid of
the monetary and market system called
the stock market
which rather than you know actually
produce anything real they just buy and
sell money itself
and when it comes to debt you know what
they do
that's right they trade it
they actually buy and sell debt for
profit
from credit default swaps and
collateralized debt obligations for
consumer debt to complex derivative
schemes used to mask the debt of entire
countries
such as the collusion of investment bank
goldman sachs in greece which nearly
collapsed the entire european economy
so when it comes to the stock market and
wall street we have an entirely new
level of insanity born out of the money
sequence of value
all you need to know about markets was
written in an editorial in the wall
street journal a couple years ago it was
called lessons of the brain damaged
investor and in this editorial they
explain why people with slight brain
damage do better as investors than
people with normal brain functionality
why because the slightly brain-damaged
person has no empathy
and that's the key if you don't have any
empathy you do well as an investor and
so wall street breeds people who have no
empathy to go in there and to make
decisions and make trades that they have
no compunction about and no thought
whatsoever as that what they're doing
might affect their fellow human being so
they breed these robots these these
people have no souls and since they
don't even want to pay these people
anymore they're now breeding robots real
robots real algorithmic traders uh
goldman sachs and the high frequency
trading scandal they put a computer next
to the exchange the new york stock
exchange this computer this co-located
computer as they call it it front runs
all the trades on the exchange and it
hits the exchanges with volumes of
orders in ways that scout pennies and
nickels away from the exchange it's just
it's like they're siphoning money all
day long they went
one quarter last year 30 or 60 straight
days without a single down day and made
millions of dollars every single day is
that because well that's statistically
impossible
when i worked on wall street the way it
works is everyone kicks upstairs the
bribes the brokers
bribe to the
office manager the office manager bribes
to the regional sales manager the
regional sales manager bribes to the
national sales manager it's a common
understanding at christmas who gets the
biggest bonus at christmas in an average
brokerage office the compliance officer
the compliance officer sits there all
day long he's supposed to be making sure
you don't violate any of the margin
rules and you're complying with the law
of course
yeah
to the extent that you can bribe the
compliance officer yeah that's right you
are complying with the law
so how does fraud has become the system
it's no longer a by-product
it is the system you know it's not that
old woody allen joke he says
doctor my brother thinks he's a chicken
and the doctor says take a pill and that
should cure the problem and he says no
doctor you don't understand we need the
eggs
okay so
the trading of fraudulent claims back
and forth between banks
to generate fees to generate bonuses has
become
the gdp
producing growth engine of the united
states economy even though they're
essentially trading fraudulent claims
that there's absolutely no hope of ever
paying back
they're processing and generating and
re-securitizing nothing if i write 20
billion dollars on a cocktail napkin and
i sell to jp morgan while jp morgan
writes 20 billion dollars on a cocktail
napkin and we swap those two cocktail
napkins at a bar and we each pay
ourselves a quarter of one percent and a
fee
we make a lot of money for a christmas
bonus we each have on our books the 20
billion cocktail napkin which has no
real value until such time as the system
is no longer able to absorb bogus
cocktail napkins in which case we go to
the government to get bailed out
and because of wall street and the
global stock market there are now
conservatively about 700 trillion
dollars of outstanding fraudulent claims
known as derivatives
still waiting to collapse
a value amounting to over 10 times the
gross domestic product of the entire
planet
and while we have seen the bailouts of
corporations and banks by governments
which of course comedically borrow their
money from banks to begin with
we are now seeing attempts to bail out
whole countries by conglomerates of
other countries through the
international banks
but how do you bail out a planet
there is no country out there that isn't
now saturated in debt
the cascade of sovereign debt defaults
we have seen can only be the beginning
when the math is taken into account
it has been estimated in the united
states alone that income tax would need
to be raised to 65 percent per person
just to cover the interest in the near
future
economists are now foreshadowing that
within a few decades 60 percent of the
countries on the planet will be bankrupt
but
hold on let me get this straight
the world is going
bankrupt whatever the hell that means
because of this idea called debt which
doesn't even exist in the physical
reality
it's only part of a game that we've
invented and yet the well-being of
billions of people
is now being compromised
extreme layoffs
tense cities accelerating poverty
austerity measures imposed
schools shutting down child hunger and
other levels of familial deprivation
all because of this elaborate fiction
what are we [ __ ] stupid
hey hey mars my man help a brother out
huh
grow up kids
[Music]
saturn what's up man
you remember that smoking nebula i
hooked you up with a while back
uh listen ice we're getting really tired
of you
you've been given everything and yet you
waste it all yeah you got plenty of
resources and you know it
why don't you grow up and learn some
responsibility for christ's sake
you're making your mother miserable
you're on your own pal
yeah whatever
[Music]
now all of this considered from the
waste machine known as the market system
to the debt machine known as the
monetary system hence creating the
monetary market paradigm which defines
the global economy today
there is one consequence that runs
through the entire machine
inequality
whether it is the market system which
creates a natural gravitation towards
monopoly and power consolidation
while also generating pockets of wealthy
industries that tower over others
regardless of utility
such as the fact that top hedge fund
managers on wall street now take home
over 300 million dollars a year for
contributing literally nothing
while a scientist looking for a cure for
a disease trying to help humanity
might make sixty thousand dollars a year
if they're lucky
or whether it is the monetary system
which has class division built right
into its structure
for example if i have one million
dollars to spare and i put it into a cd
at four percent interest i will make
forty thousand dollars a year no social
contribution no nothing
however if i'm a lower class person and
have to take loans to buy my car or home
i am paying in interest which in
abstraction is going to pay that
millionaire with the four percent cd
this stealing from the poor to pay the
rich is a foundational built-in aspect
of the monetary system and it could be
labeled structural classism
of course historically social
stratification has always been deemed
unfair but obviously accepted overall as
now one percent of the population owns
40 of the planet's wealth
but material fairness aside there is
something else going on underneath the
surface of inequality causing an
incredible deterioration in public
health as a whole
well i think people are often
puzzled by the contrast between the
material success of our societies
unprecedented levels of wealth
and the many social failings i mean you
know if you look at the the rates of um
drug abuse or violence or self-harm
amongst kids
or mental illness there's clearly
something
going deeply wrong with our societies
what the data that i've been describing
does
is simply shows that intuition that we
people have had for hundreds of years
that inequality is divisive and socially
corrosive that that intuition is truer
than i think we ever imagined
there are very powerful psychological
and social effects of inequality more to
do i suppose with feelings of in
superiority and inferiority
that kind of division and and maybe
going with the sort of respect
disrespect people feeling looked down on
at the bottom which by the way is why
violence is more common in more unequal
societies it's
the trigger to violence is so often
people feeling looked down and
disrespected
if there is one principle i can
emphasize
that is the most important
principle underlying the prevention of
violence
it would be equality
the single most significant factor that
affects the rate of violence is the
degree of equality versus the degree of
inequality in that society
so what one's looking at is a sort of
general social dysfunction
it's not just one or two things that go
wrong as inequality increases
it seems to be everything whether we're
talking about crime or health or mental
illness or whatever one of the really
disturbing findings out in public health
there is
never ever make the mistake of being
poor or being born poor you're
health-paced for an endless sorts of
ways something known as the health
socioeconomic gradient as you move down
from the highest strata in society in
terms of socioeconomic status every step
down health gets worse for umpteen
different diseases life expectancy gets
worse infant mortality rate everything
you could look at so a huge issue has
been
why is it that
this grading exists
totally simple obvious answer which is
if you are chronically sick you're not
going to be very productive so health
causes drive socioeconomic differences
not that in the slightest on the very
simple level that you could look at
socioeconomic status of a ten-year-old
and that's going to predict something
about their health decades later so
that's the direction of causality
next one what's it about oh it's
perfectly obvious poor people can't
afford to go to the doctor it's
healthcare access it's got nothing to do
with that because you see these same
gradients in countries with universal
healthcare socialized medicine
okay next simple explanation oh on the
average the poorer you are the more
likely you are to smoke to drink to all
sorts of lifestyle risk factor stuff
yeah those contribute but careful
studies have shown that explains maybe
about a third of the variability
so what's left and what's left is having
a ton to do with the stress of poverty
so the poorer you are starting off being
you know the person who's one dollar
income behind bill gates the poorer you
are in this country on the average the
worse your health is this tells us
something really important the health
connection with poverty it's not about
being poor it's about feeling poor
increasingly
we recognize that
chronic stress is an important influence
on health
but the most important sources of stress
are the quality of social relations
and if there is anything that lowers the
quality of social relations it is the
socioeconomic stratification of society
what science has now shown is that
regardless of material wealth
the stress of simply living in a
stratified society leads to a vast
spectrum of public health problems
and the greater the inequality
the worse they become
life expectancy
longer and more equal countries
drug abuse
less and more equal countries
mental illness
less and more equal countries
social capital meaning the ability of
people to trust each other
naturally greater and more equal
countries
educational scores
higher in more equal countries homicide
rates
less in more equal countries
crime and rates of imprisonment
less in more equal countries
it goes on and on
infant mortality obesity teen birth rate
less and more equal countries and
perhaps most interesting
innovation
greater in more equal countries which
challenges the age-old notion that a
competitive stratified society is
somehow more creative and inventive
moreover a study done in the uk called
the white hall study confirmed that
there is a social distribution of
disease as you go from the top of the
socioeconomic ladder to the bottom for
example it was found that the lowest
rungs of the hierarchy had a four-fold
increase of heart disease based
mortality compared to the highest rungs
and this pattern exists irrespective of
access to health care
hence the worse a person's relative
financial status the worse their health
is going to be on average
this phenomenon is rooted in what could
be termed psychosocial stress and it is
at the foundation of the greatest social
distortions plaguing our society today
its cause
the monetary market system
make no mistake
the greatest destroyer of ecology the
greatest source of waste and depletion
and pollution
the greatest purveyor of violence war
crime poverty animal abuse and
inhumanity the greatest generator of
social and personal neuroses
mental disorders depression anxiety
not to mention the greatest source of
social paralysis
stopping us from moving into new
methodologies for personal health global
sustainability and progress on this
planet
is not some corrupt government or
legislation
not some rogue corporation or banking
cartel
not some flaw of human
nature and not some secret hidden cabal
that controls the world
it is in fact the socioeconomic system
itself
at its very foundation
[Music]
let's imagine for a moment we had the
option to redesign human civilization
from the ground up what if
hypothetically speaking we discovered an
exact replica of the planet earth and
the only difference between this new
planet and our current one is that human
evolution had not occurred it was an
open palette no countries no cities no
pollution no republicans just pristine
open environment
so what would we do
well first we need a goal right
and it's safe to say that goal would be
to survive
and not to just survive but to do so in
an optimized healthy prosperous way
most people indeed desire to live and
they would prefer to do so without
suffering
therefore the basis of this civilization
needs to be as supportive and hence
sustainable for human life as possible
taking into account the material needs
of all the world's people while trying
to remove anything that could hurt us in
the long run
that goal of say maximum sustainability
understood the next question regards our
method
what kind of approach do we take
well let's see
last i checked politics was the method
of social operation on earth so what do
the doctrines of the republicans
liberals conservatives or socialists
have to say
about societal design
hmm
not a damn thing
okay then what about religion surely the
great creator had to have left some
blueprints somewhere
nope nothing i can find
okay then so what's left
it appears something called science
science is unique in that its methods
demand not only that the idea is
proposed be tested and replicated but
everything science comes up with is also
inherently falsifiable
in other words unlike religion and
politics science has no ego and
everything it suggests accepts the
possibility of being proven wrong
eventually
it holds on to nothing and evolves
constantly
well that sounds natural enough to me
so then based on the current state of
scientific knowledge in the early 21st
century along with our goal of maximum
sustainability for the human population
how do we begin the actual process of
construction
well the first question to ask what do
we need to survive
the answer of course are planetary
resources
whether it is the water we drink the
energy we use the raw materials we
utilize to create tools and shelter the
planet hosts an inventory of resources
many of which are demanded for our
survival
so given that reality it then becomes
critical to figure out what we have and
where it is
this means we need to conduct a survey
we simply locate and identify every
physical resource on the planet we can
along with the amount available at each
location from the deposits of copper to
the most potent locations for wind farms
to produce energy to the natural
freshwater springs to an assessment of
the amount of fish in the ocean to the
most prime arable land for food
cultivation etc
but since we humans are going to be
consuming these resources over time we
then realize that not only do we need to
locate and identify
we also need to track we need to make
sure we don't run out of any of this
stuff that would be bad
and this means not only tracking our
rates of use but the rates of earthly
regeneration as well
such as how long it takes for say a tree
to grow or a spring to replenish
this is called dynamic equilibrium
in other words if we use up trees faster
than they can be grown back we have a
serious problem for it is
unsustainable so then how do we track
this inventory especially when we
recognize that all of this stuff is
scattered everywhere
we have large mineral mines in what we
call africa
energy concentrations in the middle east
huge tidal power possibilities on the
atlantic coast of north america the
largest supply of fresh water in brazil
etc
well once again good old science has a
suggestion
it's called systems theory systems
theory recognizes that the fabric of the
natural world from human biology to the
earthly biosphere to the gravitational
pull of the solar system itself is one
huge synergistically connected system
fully interlinked
just as human cells connect to form our
organs and the organs connect to form
our bodies and since our bodies cannot
live without the earthly resources of
food air and water we are intrinsically
connected to the earth and so on
so as nature suggests we take all of
this inventory and tracking data and
create a system to manage it a global
resource management system in fact to
account for every relevant resource on
the planet there is simply no logical
alternative if our goal as a species is
survival in the long run we have to keep
track as a whole
that understood we can now consider
production
how do we use all this stuff what will
our process of production be and what do
we need to consider to make sure it is
as optimized as possible to maximize our
sustainability
well the first thing that jumps right
out at us is the fact that we need to
constantly try and preserve
the planet's resources are essentially
finite so it is important that we be
strategic
strategic preservation is key
the second thing we recognize is that
some resources are really not as good as
others in their performance in fact some
of this stuff when put into use has a
terrible effect on the environment which
invariably hinders our own health
for example oil and fossil fuels no
matter how you cut it release some
pretty destructive agents into the
environment
therefore it is critical we do our best
to use such things only when we really
have to if at all
fortunately for us we see a ton of solar
wind tidal wave heat differential and
geothermal possibilities for energy
production so we can strategize
objectively about what we use and where
to avoid what could be called
negative retro actions or anything that
results from production or use that
damages the environment and hence
ourselves
we will call this strategic safety to
couple in with our strategic
preservation
but production strategies do not stop
there we are going to need an efficiency
strategy for the actual mechanics of
production itself
and what we find is that there are
roughly three specific protocols we must
adhere to
one every good we produce must be
designed to last as long as possible
naturally the more things break down the
more resources we are going to need to
replace them and the more waste produced
two when things do break down or are no
longer usable for whatever reason it is
critical that we harvest or recycle as
much as we possibly can
so the production design must take this
into account directly at the very
earliest stages
three
quickly evolving technologies such as
electronics which are subject to the
fastest rates of technological
obsolescence would need to be designed
to foreshadow and accommodate physical
updates
the last thing we want to do is throw
away an entire computer system just
because it has only one broken part or
is outdated so we simply design the
components to be easily updated part by
part
standardized and universally
interchangeable foreshadowed by the
current trend of technological change
and when we realize that the mechanisms
of strategic preservation strategic
safety and strategic efficiency are
purely technical considerations
devoid of any human opinion or bias
we simply program these strategies into
a computer which can weigh and calculate
all the relevant variables allowing us
to always arrive at the absolute best
method for sustainable production based
on current understandings
and while that might sound complex all
it is is a glorified calculator not to
mention such multivariate decision
making and monitoring systems are
already used across the world today for
isolated purposes
it is simply a process of scaling it out
so
now we not only have our resource
management system but also a production
management system
both of which are easily computer
automated to maximize efficiency
preservation and safety
the informational reality is that the
human mind or even a group of humans
cannot track what needs to be tracked it
must be done by computers and it can be
and this brings us to the next level
distribution
what sustainability strategies make
sense here
well since we know that the shortest
distance between two points is a
straight line and since energy is
required to power transport machines the
less transport distance the more
efficient
producing goods in one continent and
shipping them over to another only makes
sense if the goods in question simply
cannot be produced in the target area
otherwise it is nothing but wasteful
we must localize production so
distribution is simple fast and requires
the least amount of energy
we'll call this the proximity strategy
which simply means we reduce the travel
of goods as much as possible whether raw
materials or finished consumer products
of course it might also be important to
know what goods we are transporting and
why
and this falls under the category of
demand
and demand is simply what people need to
be healthy and to have a high quality of
life
the spectrum of material human needs
range from core life-supporting
necessities such as food clean water
shelter
to social and recreational goods which
allow for relaxation and personal social
enjoyment
both important factors in human and
social health overall
so very simply we take another survey
people describe their needs demand is
assessed and production begins based on
that demand
and since the level of demand of
different goods will naturally fluctuate
and change around different regions we
need to create a demand distribution
tracking system so to avoid overruns and
shortages
of course this idea is old news it is
used in every major store chain today to
make sure they keep up with their
inventory only this time we are tracking
on a global scale
but wait a minute we really can't fully
understand demand if we don't account
for the actual usage of the good itself
is it logical and sustainable for every
single human to say have one of
everything made regardless of their
usage
no
that would be simply wasteful and
inefficient
if a person has a need for a good but
that need is only for say 45 minutes a
day on average
it would be much more efficient if that
good was made available to them
and to others when needed
many forget that it isn't the good that
they want it is the purpose of that good
when we realize that the good itself is
only as important as its utility
we see that external restriction or what
we might call today ownership is
extremely wasteful and environmentally
illogical in a fundamental economic
sense
so we need to devise a strategy called
strategic access
this would be the foundation of our
demand distribution tracking system
which makes sure we can meet the demand
of the population's needs for access of
whatever they need when they need it
and as far as physically obtaining the
goods
centralized and regional access centers
all make sense for the most part
placed in close proximity to the
population and a person would simply
come in take the item use it and when
finished return it when it is no longer
needed sort of how a library works today
in fact these centers could not only
exist in the community and the way we
see local stores today
but specialized access centers would
exist in specific areas where often
certain goods are utilized saving more
energy with less repeat transport
and once this demand tracking system is
in order it is tied into our production
management system and of course into our
resource management system hence
creating a unified dynamically updating
global economic management machine
that simply makes sure we remain
sustainable starting with securing the
integrity of our finite resources
moving to make sure we only create the
best most strategic goods possible
while distributing everything in the
most intelligent and efficient way
and the unique result of this
preservation-based approach
which is intuitively counter to many
is that this logical ground-up empirical
process of preservation and efficiency
which can only define true human
sustainability on this planet
would likely enable something never
before seen in human history
access abundance
not just for a percentage of the global
population
but the entire civilization
this economic model as was just
generalized this responsible systems
approach to total earth resource
management and processes designed again
to do nothing less than take care of
humanity as a whole in the most
efficient and sustainable way
could be termed a resource
economy
the idea was defined in the 1970s by
structural engineer jacques fresco he
understood back then that society was on
a collision course with nature and
itself unsustainable on every level
and if things didn't change we would
destroy ourselves one way or another
are all these things you're saying
jacques
could they be built with what we know
today or are some of these things are
you guessing based on what we know today
no
all of these things can be built with
what we know today it would take 10
years to change the surface of the earth
to rebuild the world into a second
garden of eden the choice lies with you
the stupidity of a nuclear arms race the
development of weapons trying to solve
your problems politically by electing
this political party or that political
party that all politics is immersed in
corruption let me say it again communism
socialism fascism the democrats the
liberals we want to absorb human beings
all organizations that believe in the
better life of man there are no negro
problems or polish problems or jewish
problems or greek problems or women's
problems they're human problems i'm not
afraid of anybody i don't work for
anyone no one can discharge me i have no
boss i am afraid to live in the society
we live in today our society cannot be
maintained by this type of incompetency
it was great the free enterprise system
about 35 years ago that was the last of
its usefulness now we've got to change
our way of thinking or perish
the horror movies of the future would be
our society the way it didn't work
and politics would be part of a horror
movie
lots of people today use the term cold
science
because they're analytical
and they don't even know what analytical
means
science means closer approximations of
the way the world really works
so it's telling the truth
is what it is a scientist doesn't try to
get along with people they tell them
what their findings are they have to
question
all things and if some scientist comes
up with an experiment that shows
certain materials have certain strength
other scientists have to be able to
duplicate that experiment and come up
with the same results
even if a scientist feels
that an airplane wing
due to mathematics or calculations can
hold up a given amount of weight they
still pile sandbags on it to see when it
breaks and they say you know my
calculations are right or they're not
correct i love that system because it's
free of bias and free of thinking that
math can solve all the problems you have
to put your math to test also
i think that every system that can be
put to test should be put to test and
then all decisions should be based upon
research
a resource-based economy is simply the
scientific method applied to social
concern an approach utterly absent in
the world today
society is a technical invention and the
most efficient methods of optimized
human health physical production
distribution city infrastructure and the
like
reside in the field of science and
technology not politics or monetary
economics
it operates in the same systematic way
as say an airplane and there is no
republican or liberal way to build an
airplane
likewise nature itself is the physical
referent we use to prove our science and
it is a set system emerging only from
our increased understanding of it
in fact it has no regard for what you
subjectively think or believe to be true
rather it gives you an option you can
learn and fall in line with its natural
laws and conduct yourself accordingly
invariably creating good health and
sustainability
or you can go against the current to no
avail
it doesn't matter how much you believe
you can just stand up right now and walk
on the wall next to you the law of
gravity will not allow it if you do not
eat you will die
if you are not touched as an infant you
will die
as harsh as it may sound nature is a
dictatorship and we can either listen to
it and come in harmony with it or suffer
the inevitable adverse consequences
so a resource-based economy is nothing
more than a set of proven
life-supporting understandings where all
decisions are based upon optimized human
and environmental sustainability
it takes into account the empirical life
ground which every human being shares as
a need regardless again of their
political or religious philosophy
there is no cultural relativism to this
approach it isn't a matter of opinion
human needs are human needs and having
access to the necessities of life such
as clean air nutritious food and clean
water
along with a positively reinforcing
stable nurturing and non-violent
environment is demanded for our mental
and physical health our evolutionary
fitness and hence the species survival
itself
a resource-based economy
would be based upon available resources
you can't just bring a lot of people to
an island or build a city of 50 000
people without having access to the
necessities of life so when i use the
term a comprehensive systems approach
i'm talking about doing an inventory of
the area first
and determining what that area can
supply not just architectural approach
not just
design approach but design must be based
on all of the requirements to enhance
human life and that's what i mean by an
integrated way of thinking
food clothing shelter warms love all
those things are necessary
if you deprive people of any of them
you have a lesser human being
less capable of functioning
as previously outlined a resource-based
economy's ground-up global systems
approach to extraction production and
distribution
is based upon a set of true economic
mechanisms or strategies which guarantee
efficiency and sustainability in every
area of the economy
so continuing this train of thought
regarding logical design
what is next in our equation where does
all this materialize
cities
the advent of the city is a defining
feature of modern civilization its role
is to enable efficient access to the
necessities of life along with increased
social support and community interaction
so how would we go about designing an
ideal city what shape should we make it
square trapezoid
well given we're going to be moving
around the thing we might as well make
it as equidistant as possible for ease
hence the circle
what should the city contain
well naturally we need a residential
area a goods production area a power
generation area an agricultural area
but we also need nurturing as human
beings hence culture
nature recreation and education so let's
include a nice open park an
entertainment events area for cultural
purposes and socializing
and educational and research facilities
and since we're working with a circle it
seems rational to place these functions
in belts
based on the amount of land required for
each goal along with ease of access
very good
now let's get down to specifics
first we need to consider the core
infrastructure or intestines of the city
organism
these would be the water good waste and
energy transport channels
just as we have water and sewage systems
under our cities today we would extend
this channeling concept to integrate
waste recycling and delivery itself
no more mailman or garbage men
it is built right in we could even use
automated pneumatic tubes and similar
technologies
same goes for transport it needs to be
integrated and strategically designed to
reduce or even remove the need for
wasteful independent automobiles
electric trams conveyors transverse and
maglev's which can take you virtually
anywhere in the city even up and down
along with connecting you to other
cities as well
and of course in the event an automobile
is required it is automated by satellite
for safety and integrity in fact this
automation technology is in working
order right now
automobile accidents kill about 1.2
million people every single year
injuring about 50 million this is absurd
and doesn't have to occur
between efficient city design and
automated driverless cars this death
toll can be virtually eliminated
agriculture
today through our haphazard cost-cutting
industrial methods using pesticides
excessive fertilizers and other means
we have successfully destroyed much of
the arable land on this planet not to
mention also extensively poisoning our
bodies in fact industrial and
agricultural chemical toxins now show up
in virtually every human being tested
including infants
fortunately there is a glaring
alternative
the soilless mediums of hydroponics and
aeroponics which also reduce nutrient
and water requirements by up to 75
percent of our current usage
food can now be organically grown on an
industrial scale in enclosed vertical
farms
such as in 50-story one-acre plots
virtually eliminating the need for
pesticides and hydrocarbons in general
this is the future of industrial food
cultivation efficient clean and abundant
so such advanced systems would be in
part what comprise our agricultural belt
producing all the food required for the
entire city's population with no need to
import anything from the outside saving
time waste and energy
and speaking of energy
the energy belt would work in a systems
approach to extract electricity from our
abundant renewable mediums specifically
wind solar geothermal and heat
differentials and if near water
potentials tidal and wave power
to avoid intermittency and make sure a
positive net energy return occurs these
mediums will operate in an integrated
system powering each other when needed
while storing excessive energy to large
super capacitors under the ground so
nothing can go to waste
and not only does the city power itself
particular structures will also power
independently and generate electricity
through photovoltaic paints structural
pressure transducers the thermal couple
effect and other current but
underutilized technologies
but of course this begs the question how
does this technology and goods in
general get created in the first place
this brings us to production
the industrial belt apart from having
hospitals and the like would be the hub
of factory production completely
localized overall it would of course
obtain raw materials by way of the
global resource management system just
discussed with demand being generated by
the population of the city itself
as far as the mechanics of production we
need to discuss a new powerful
phenomenon which was sparked very
recently in human history and is on pace
to changing everything
it's called mechanization
or the automation of labor well if you
look around you you'll notice that
almost everything that we use today
is built automatically
your shoes your clothes your home
appliances your car and so on
they are all built by machines
in an automatic way
can we say that the society has not been
influenced by these major technological
advancements of course not these
systems really dictate new structures
and new needs
and they make a lot of other things
obsolete
so we've been going up uh in the
development and use of technology in an
exponential way so definitely
automation is going to continue you
cannot stop
the technologies that just make sense
labor automation through technology is
at the bottom of every major social
transformation in human history from the
agricultural revolution and the
invention of the plow to the industrial
revolution and the invention of the
powered machine to the information age
we live in now through essentially the
invention of advanced electronics and
computers
and with regard to advanced production
methods today mechanization is now
evolving on its own
moving away from the traditional method
of assembling component parts into a
configuration into an advanced method of
creating entire products in one single
process
like most engineers i'm fascinated by
biology because it's so full of examples
of
extraordinary pieces of engineering um
and absolutely what biology is the study
of things that copy themselves of course
good definition of life as we've got
again as an engineer i've always been
intrigued by the idea of machines that
would copy themselves
reprap is a three-dimensional printer
that's to say it's a printer that you
plug into a computer and instead of
making two-dimensional sheets of paper
with patterns on it makes real physical
three-dimensional objects
now there's nothing new about that uh 3d
printers have been around for about 30
years
big thing about rep ram
is that it prints most of its own parts
so if you've got one you can make
another one and give it to a friend as
well as being able to print lots of
useful things
from the simple printing of basic
household goods in your home to the
printing of an entire automobile body in
one swoop
advanced automated 3d printing now has
the potential to transform virtually
every field of production including home
construction
contour crafting is
actually a fabrication technology
the so-called 3d printing when you
directly build
a 3d
object from a computer model
using counter crafting it will be
possible to build a 2 000 square foot
home
entirely by the machine in one day
the reason that
people are interested in automating
construction is that it really brings a
lot of benefits
for example construction is pretty labor
intensive and although it provides job
for a sector of the society
it also
has issues
and
complications for example construction
is the most dangerous job that there is
it is worse than mining and agriculture
it has got the highest level of fatality
almost in every country
another issue is the waste
an average home in united states has
three to seven tons of waste
so this is huge uh if we
look at the impact of construction and
and knowing that about 40 percent of all
materials in the world are used in
construction so a big
waste of
energy and resources and big damage to
the environment as well
making homes using
hammers and nails and wood with the
state of our technology today is really
absurd and will go the way of our labor
class in regards to manufacturing in the
united states
recently there was a study by economist
david octor of mit
that states that our middle class is
obsolete and being replaced by
automation
quite simply mechanization is more
productive efficient and sustainable
than human labor in virtually every
sector of the economy today
machines do not need vacations breaks
insurance pensions and they can work 24
hours a day every day
the output potential and accuracy
compared to human labor is unmatched
the bottom line repetitive human labor
is becoming obsolete and impractical
across the world and the unemployment
you see around you today is
fundamentally the result of this
evolution of efficiency in technology
for years market economists have
dismissed this growing pattern which
could be called technological
unemployment because of the fact that
new sectors always seem to emerge to
reabsorb the displaced workers
today the service sector is the only
real hub left and currently employs over
80 percent of the american workforce
with most industrialized countries
maintaining a similar proportion however
this sector is now being challenged
increasingly by automated kiosks
automated restaurants and even automated
stores
economists today are finally
acknowledging what they have been
denying for years
not only is technological unemployment
exasperating the current labor crisis we
see across the world due to the global
economic downturn
but the more the recession deepens the
faster the industries are mechanizing
the catch which is not realized is that
the faster they mechanize to save money
the more they displace people the more
they reduce public purchasing power
this means that while the corporation
can produce everything more cheaply
fewer and fewer people will actually
have money to buy anything regardless of
how cheap they become
the bottom line is that the labor for
income game is slowly coming to an end
in fact if you take a moment to reflect
on the jobs which are in existence today
which automation could take over right
now if applied
75 of the global workforce could be
replaced by mechanization tomorrow
and this is why in a resource-based
economy there is no monetary market
system
no money at all
for there is no need
a resource-based economy recognizes the
efficiency of mechanization and accepts
it for what it offers it doesn't fight
it like we do today
why because it is irresponsible not to
given any interest in efficiency and
sustainability
and this brings us back to our city
system
in the center is the central dome which
not only houses the educational
facilities and transportation hub it
also hosts the mainframe that runs the
city's technical operations
the city is in fact one big automated
machine it has sensors and all technical
belts to track the progress of
agriculture energy gathering production
distribution and the like
now would people be needed to oversee
these operations in the event of a
malfunction or the like
most probably yes but that number would
decrease over time as improvements
continue
however as of today maybe three percent
of the city population would be needed
for this job when you break it down
and i can assure you that in an economic
system which is actually designed to
take care of you and secure your
well-being
without you having to submit to a
private dictatorship on a daily basis
usually to a job that is either
technically unnecessary
or socially pointless
while often struggling with debt that
doesn't exist just to make ends meet
i guarantee you people will volunteer
their time
left and right to maintain and improve a
system that actually takes care of them
and coupled with this issue of incentive
comes the common assumption that if
there isn't some external pressure for
one to work for a living people will
just sit around do nothing and turn into
fat lazy blobs
this is nonsense
the labor system we have today is in
fact the generator of laziness
not a resolver of it
if you think back to when you're a child
full of life interested in new things to
understand likely creating and exploring
but as time went on the system pushed
you into the focus of figuring out how
to make money
and from early education to study at a
university you are narrowed only to
emerge as a creature which serves as a
cog in a wheel in a model that sends all
the fruits to the upper one percent
scientific studies have now shown that
people are in fact not motivated by
monetary reward when it comes to
ingenuity and creation
the creation itself is the reward
money in fact appears only to serve as
an incentive for repetitive mundane
actions a role we have just now shown
can be replaced by machine
so when it comes to innovation the
actual use of the human mind the
monetary incentive has proven to be a
hindrance interfering and detracting
from creative thought
and this might explain why nikola tesla
the wright brothers and other inventors
who contributed massively to our current
world never showed a monetary incentive
to do so
money is in fact a false incentive and
causes a hundred times more distortion
than it does contribution
[Music]
good morning class please settle down
the first thing i would like to do is go
around the room and ask what everyone
would like to be when they grow up
who would like to go first
okay how about you sarah
when i grow up i want to work at
mcdonald's like my mom
oh family tradition eh
how about you linda
when i grow up i'm gonna be a prostitute
on the streets of new york city
glamour girl huh very ambitious
how about you tommy
when i grow up i'm gonna be a rich
elitist businessman who works on wall
street and profits off of the collapse
of foreign economies
enterprising
and great to see some multicultural
interest
[Music]
as stated before a resource-based
economy applies the scientific method to
social concern and this isn't limited to
simply technical efficiency
it also has the consideration of human
and social well-being directly and what
comprises it
what good is a social system if in the
end it doesn't produce happiness and
peaceful coexistence
so it is important to point out that
with the removal of the money system and
the necessities of life provided we
would see a global reduction in crime by
about 95 percent almost immediately for
there is nothing to steal embezzle scam
or the like
95 percent of all people in prisons
today are there due to some monetary
related crime or drug abuse
and drug abuse is a disorder not a crime
so what about the other five percent the
truly violent
often seeming to some as being violent
for the sake of being violent
are they just evil people
the reason that i
frankly
think it's a waste of time
to engage in moral value judgments
about
people's violence is because it doesn't
advance by one
iota
our understanding of either the causes
or the prevention
of the violent behavior
people sometimes ask if i believe in
forgiving criminals
my answer to that is no i don't believe
in forgiveness
any more than i believe in condemnation
it's only if we as a society can take
the same attitude of treating violence
as a problem in public health and
preventive medicine
rather than as a moral evil
it's only when we make that change in
our own attitudes and assumptions and
values
that we will actually succeed
in reducing the level of violence rather
than stimulating it which is what we do
now
the more justice you seek the more hurt
you become because there's no thing as
justice there is whatever there is out
there
that's it in other words if people are
conditioned to be racist bigots if
they're brought up in an environment
that as a case said why do you blame the
person for it they're a victim of a
subculture
therefore they have to be helped the
point is we have to redesign the
environment that reduces aberrant
behavior that's the problem not putting
a person in jail
that's why
judges lawyers
freedom of choice such concepts
are dangerous because it gives you
misinformation
that the person is bad or that person is
a serial killer
serial killers are made just like
soldiers become serial killers with a
machine gun
they become killing machines but nobody
looks at them as murderers or assassins
because that's natural
so we blame people we say well this guy
was a nazi he taught the jews no he was
brought up to torture jews
once you accept the fact that people
have individual choices and they're free
to make those choices free to make
choices means without being influenced
and i can't understand that at all all
of us are influenced in all our choices
by the culture we live in by our parents
and by the values that dominate so we're
influenced so they can't be free choices
what's the greatest country in the world
the true answer i haven't been all over
the world and i don't know if you know
enough about different cultures to
answer that question
i don't know anybody that speaks that
way as i said good old usa the greatest
country in the world there's no survey
have you been to india no you've been to
england no have you been to france no
what do you make your assumptions on
they can't answer they get mad at you
because well god damn it who the hell
are you to tell me what to think yeah
don't forget you're dealing with
aberrated people they're not responsible
for their answers they're victims of
culture that means they've been
influenced by their culture
[Music]
[Music]
when we consider a resource
resource-based economy there are often a
number of arguments that tend to come up
with regard to the efficiency hey hey
now hold on just a minute yes
i know what this is this is called
marxism buddy stalin killed 800 billion
people because of ideas like this my
father died in the gulag hold on
communist fascist you don't like america
you should just leave everybody just
calm down
and as the irrationality of the audience
grew shocked and confused suddenly the
narrator suffered a fatal heart attack
and the seemingly communist propaganda
film was no more
[Music]
you know i've said that sort of thing to
people in think tank type of situations
and uh you know these club of rome types
and so forth
marxist
what marxists where did that come from
you know they just they've got this icon
they hold on to it's their holy grail
and it's such an easy one you know
people ask if i'm a socialist or a
communist or a capitalist and i say i'm
none of the above and why do you think
why do you think that those are the only
options
all of those political constructs were
created by writers who assumed that we
lived on a planet of infinite resources
not a one of those political
philosophies even
contemplates that there might be a
shortage of anything i believe that
communism socialism free enterprise
fascism are part of social evolution
that you can't take a giant step from
one culture to another but they're in
between systems before there's any ism
we've got a life ground and the
lifeground is as i just described most
easily it's all the conditions required
to take your next breath and that
involves the air you breathe the water
you get the safety you have the
education you can access all these
things that we share and use and that no
life in any culture can do without so
we've got to reset
down to the life ground and the
lifeground is no longer any ism it's
life value analysis
it's simply a matter of historical fact
that the dominant intellectual culture
of any particular society reflects the
interest of the dominant group in that
society
in a slave-owning society the beliefs
about human beings and human rights and
so on will reflect the needs of the
slave owners
in a society which again is based on
the power of
certain people to control and profit
from the lives and work of millions of
others the dominant intellectual culture
will reflect the needs of the dominant
group and so that if you look across the
board the ideas that pervade psychology
and sociology and history
and political economy and political
science fundamentally reflect certain
elite interests
and the academics who question that too
much
tend to get shunted to the side or to be
seen as sort of radicals
the dominant values of a culture tend to
support and perpetuate what is rewarded
by that culture and in a society where
success and status is measured by
material wealth not social contribution
it is easy to see why the state of the
world is what it is today
we are dealing with a value system
disorder completely denatured where the
priority of personal and social health
have become secondary to the detrimental
notions of artificial wealth and
limitless growth
and like a virus this disorder now
permeates every facet of government
news media entertainment and even
academia
and built into its structure are
mechanisms of protection from anything
that might interfere
disciples of the monetary market
religion the self-appointed guardians of
the status quo
constantly seek out ways to avoid any
form of thought which might interfere
with their beliefs the most common of
which are projected dualities
if you are not a republican you must be
a democrat if you are not a christian
you might be a satanist and if you feel
society can be greatly improved to
consider perhaps i don't know taking
care of everyone
you're just a utopianist
and the most insidious of them all if
you are not for the free market you must
be against freedom itself
i'm a believer in freedom
every time you hear the word freedom
being said anywhere or government
interference said anywhere it means
decoded
blocking maximization of turning money
into more money for private money
possessors
that's it every other thing they'll say
oh we need more commodities for people
all this uh
freedom uh against tyranny and so forth
every time you see it you can decode it
down to that and i think you'll find a
one-to-one correlation with every time
they use it and this is a sense in which
we might call
it's a syntax a governing syntax of
understanding and a value
so that it governs beneath their own
recognition of it so they may not say oh
i didn't mean that at all but in fact
that's what they do just like you may
speak a grammar and you have rules of
grammar you follow without recognizing
what the rules are and so what we have
is what i call the ruling value syntax
that underlies this so every time they
use these words government interference
lack of freedom or freedom or
progress or development you can decode
them all to come back to mean that
of course when you hear the word freedom
it tends to be in the same sentence with
something called democracy
it's fascinating how people today seem
to believe that they actually have a
relevant influence on what their
government does
forgetting that the very nature of our
system offers everything for sale
the only vote that counts is the
monetary vote and it doesn't matter how
much any activist yells about ethics or
accountability in a market system every
politician every legislation and hence
every government is for sale
and even with the 20 trillion dollar
bank bailout starting in 2007 an amount
of money which could have changed say
the global energy infrastructure to
fully renewable methods instead going to
a series of institutions that literally
do nothing to help society institutions
that could be removed tomorrow with no
recourse
the blind conditioning that politics and
politicians exist for the public
well-being still continues
the fact is politics is a business no
different than any other in a market
system and they care about their
self-interest before anything else
i don't really honestly deep down
believe in political action i think the
system contracts and expands as it wants
to it accommodates these changes i think
the civil rights movement was an
accommodation on the part of those who
own the country
i think they see where their
self-interest lies they see a certain
amount of freedom seems good an illusion
of liberty give these people a voting
day every year so that they'll have the
illusion of meaningless choice
meaningless choice that we go like
slaves and say you are i voted the
limits of debate in this country are
established before the debate even
begins and everyone else is marginalized
they're made to seem either to be
communist or some sort of disloyal
person a kook there's a word and now
it's conspiracy see they've made that
something that should not be even
entertained for a minute that powerful
people might get together and have a
plan doesn't happen you're a kook you're
a conspiracy buff
and of all the mechanisms of defense of
this system there are two that
repeatedly come up
the first is this idea that the system
has been the cause of the material
progress we have seen on this planet
well
no
there are basically two root causes
which have created the increased
so-called wealth and population growth
we see today
one the exponential advancement of
production technology hence scientific
ingenuity
and two the initial discovery of
abundant hydrocarbon energy which is
currently the foundation of the entire
socioeconomic system
the free market capitalist monetary
market system whatever you want to call
it has done nothing but ride the wave of
these advents with the distorted
incentive system and a haphazard grossly
unequal method of utilizing and
distributing those fruits
the second defense is a belligerent
social bias generated from years of
propaganda which sees any other social
system as a route to so-called tyranny
with various name droppings of stalin
mao hitler and the death tolls they
generated
well as despotic as these men might have
been along with the societal approaches
they perpetuated
when it comes to the game of death when
it comes to the systematic daily mass
murder of human beings
nothing in history compares to what we
have today
famines
throughout at least the last
century of our history have not been
caused by a lack of food they've been
caused by relative poverty the economic
resources were so inequitably
distributed
that the poor simply didn't have enough
money
with which to buy the food that would
have been available if they could have
afforded to pay for it
that would be an example of structural
violence
another example
in africa and some other areas but i'll
particularly focus on africa
tens of millions of people are dying of
aids why are they dying
it's not because we don't know how to
treat aids we have you know millions of
people in the in the wealthy countries
are getting along remarkably well
because
they have the medicines that will treat
it the people in africa who are dying of
aids are not dying because of the hiv
virus they're dying because they don't
have the money with which to pay for the
drugs that would keep them alive
gandhi saw this he said the deadliest
form of violence
is
poverty
and that's absolutely right poverty
kills far more people
than all the wars in history
more people than all the murderers in
history more than all the suicides in
history
not only does structural violence kill
more people than all the behavioral
violence put together
structural violence is also the main
cause
of behavioral violence
[Music]
oil is
the foundation of
and that is present throughout the
edifice of human civilization
there are 10 calories of hydrocarbon
energy oil and natural gas in every
calorie of food you and i eat in the
industrialized world
fertilizers are made from natural gas
pesticides are made from oil you drive
oil powered machines to plant plow
irrigate harvest transport package you
wrap the food in plastic that's oil all
plastic is oil there are seven gallons
of oil in every tire oil is everywhere
it's ubiquitous and it's only because of
oil that there are seven billion people
or almost seven billion people on this
planet right now
the arrival of this cheap easy energy
which is equivalent by the way to
billions of slaves working around the
clock
uh
changed the world in such a radical way
over the last century and the population
has gone up 10 times
but by 2050
oil supply is able to support less than
half the present world's population in
their present way of life
so the scale of adjustment to live
differently is just
enormous the world is now using six
barrels of oil for every barrel it finds
five years ago it was using four barrels
of oil for every barrel it finds a year
from now it's going to be using eight
barrels of oil for every barrel it finds
what's disturbing to me is the
lack of any real effort from governments
worldwide or
industry leaders worldwide to do
something different
i mean we have these sort of
attempts to build more wind power and to
maybe do something with thai
we've got attempts to make our cars a
little bit more um efficient but there's
nothing which really looks like a
revolution coming along these are all
pretty minor and that i think is pretty
frightening
and the governments who are driven by
these economists who don't really
appreciate what we're talking about
are trying to stimulate consumerism to
restore past prosperity
in the hope that they can restore the
past they're printing yet more money
lacking any collateral at all
so if if the economy improves and
recovers and growth famous growth comes
back it'll only be short-lived because
within
a short period of time counted in months
rather than years
it'll hit the supply barrier again
there'll be another price shock and a
deeper recession so i think we go into a
series of vicious circles so you have
the economic growth going up price spike
everything shuts down that's where we
are now then it starts to come up again
but what we have now is this
is this area where there's there's no
more ability to produce cheap energy
we're at the peak we're on the downslope
of oil production
no way you're going to get any more out
of the ground any faster
which means that things shut down the
price of oil drops which it did in the
early 2009 but then as you have an air
zot so-called recovery the price of oil
starts to come back it's recently been
hovering around eighty dollars a barrel
and what we see is that eighty dollars a
barrel now with the economic and
financial collapse people are having a
hard time affording that world oil
production uh right now is about 86
million barrels a day
over 10 years
you're looking at
roughly 40 40 million barrels a day
having to be replaced
there's nothing around which can come
even
within a one percent of meeting that
sort of demand if we don't do something
pretty quickly there's going to be a
huge energy deficiency
i think the big mistake is in not
recognizing um
a decade or so ago
that an effort a concerted effort needed
to be made to develop these sustainable
forms of energy i think that's something
our grandchildren will look back on with
total
disbelief you people knew that you were
dealing with a finite commodity how
could you possibly have built your
economy around something which was going
to disappear
for the first time in human history the
species is now faced with the depletion
of a core resource central to our
current system of survival and the punch
line of the whole thing is that even
with oil becoming more and more scarce
the economic system will still blindly
push its cancerous growth model so
people can go out and buy more
oil-powered cars to generate gdp and
jobs exacerbating the decline
are there solutions to replace the
edifice of the hydrocarbon economy of
course
but the path needed to accomplish these
changes will not manifest through the
market system protocols required since
new solutions can only be implemented
through the profit mechanism
people are not investing in renewable
energies because there is no money in it
in both the long and short term and the
commitment needed to make it happen can
only occur at a severe financial loss
hence there is no monetary incentive and
in this system if there's no monetary
incentive things do not happen
and on top of it all peak oil is just
one of many surfacing consequences of
the environmental social train wreck
gaining speed today
other declines include fresh water the
very fabric of our existence which is
currently showing shortages for 2.8
billion people and those shortages are
on pace to reach 4 billion by 2030.
food production
the destruction of arable cropland from
which 99.7 percent of all human food
comes from today is occurring up to 40
times faster than it is being
replenished and over the last 40 years
30 percent of the arable land has become
unproductive
not to mention that hydrocarbons are the
backbone of agriculture today and as it
declines so will the food supply
as far as resources in general and our
current patterns of consumption by 2030
we will need two planets to continue our
rates
not to mention the continual destruction
of life supporting biodiversity
causing extinction spasms and
environmental destabilization across the
globe
and with all of these declines we have
the near exponential population growth
whereby 2030 there might be over 8
billion people on this planet
energy production alone would need to
increase 44
by 2030 to meet such demand
and again
since money is the only initiator of
action are we to expect that any country
on the planet is going to be able to
afford the massive changes needed to
revolutionize agriculture water
processing energy production and the
like
when the global debt pyramid scheme is
slowly shutting the entire world down
not to mention the fact that the
unemployment you currently see is going
to become normality due to the nature of
technological unemployment the jobs are
not coming back
and finally a broad social perspective
from 1970 to 2010 poverty on this planet
doubled due to this system and given our
current state do you honestly think we
will see anything less than more
doubling more suffering and more mass
starvation
there is not going to be any recovery
this is not some long depression that
we're someday going to pull out of i
think the next phase we're going to see
after the next round of economic
collapse is massive civil unrest when
employment checks stop being paid
because the states have no money left
and when things get so bad that people
lose confidence and they're elected
leaders they will demand change
if we don't kill each other in the
process or destroy the environment
i'm just afraid that we might get to the
point of no return
and that bothers me no end we do all we
can to avoid that condition
it's clear that we're on the verge of a
great transition in human life
the what we face now is this fundamental
change of the life we've known over the
last century
there has to be a link between the
economy and the resources of this planet
the resources being of course all animal
and plant life the health of the oceans
and everything else
this is a monetary paradigm that will
not let go until it's killed the last
human being
the in-group will do all it's can to
stay in power
and that's what you got to keep in mind
they'll use the army and navy and laws
or whatever they have to use
to keep in power they're not about to
give it up because they don't know of
any other system
they'll perpetuate their kind
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
take a straight and stronger course
to the corner of your life
[Music]
just remember that the goal
is for us all to capture
all we
[Music]
[Music]
send an instant karma to me
unless you
live for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
did
[Music]
with yourself
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
a
is
[Applause]
each day
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
you